le sang coule en Pologne cette mort et
plus de 300 blessés annoncent ce soir
radio Varsovie la réaction américaine à
la situation polonaise le président
régal parle en ce moment même réaction
française tous les syndicats sauf la CGT
appellent à une heure de grève lundi le
mauvais temps le Sud-Ouest toujours
inondé quelques stations de montagne
isolées par la neige
madame monsieur bonsoir le sang coule en
Pologne au moins 7 morts et plus de 300
blessés ce sont les organes officiels de
la presse polonaise eux-mêmes qu'il
annonce ce soir regardez le dernier
bulletin télévisé le dernier journal que
les Polonais viennent de voir
39000 blessés 41 fonctionnaires en
Silésie la télévision polonaise vient de
l'annoncer à son journal de 19h30
présentant cet événement comme une
tragédie nationale
en même temps
324 personnes
160 civils et 164 militaires ont
également été blessés en ce jour
anniversaire
de décembre 1970
la date d'aujourd'hui le 17 décembre
restera donc encore une fois marqué
d'une croix noire dans la mémoire de
millions de Polonais car il y a un an
exactement le bastion ouvrier de la
conscience polonaise les dirigeants de
solidarité les Valaisans en tête et les
dirigeants du régime main dans la main
célébraient l'anniversaire des troubles
sanglants de 1970 Philippe Rochot
à l'origine de la révolte de Gans que le
17 décembre 70 la décision du
gouvernement d'augmenter les prix de 30%
sans préavis la population du grand port
de la Baltique fait éclater sa colère et
descendant la rue on brûle les autobus
on met le feu au siège du parti dans les
commissariats de police les ouvriers des
chantiers naval font grève les blindés
quadrillent la ville la milice tire sur
les manifestants et fait une quarantaine
de morts le gouvernement polonais
s'explique il faut en finir avec le
désordre 400 personnes sont arrêtées
dont un inconnu lèche valaisa ces
émeutes sont la première fissure dans le
régime polonais elle provoque la chute
de gomulca remplacée par Edward Guirec
qui promet le dialogue avec la classe
ouvrière mais il tombera ne vend plus
tard face à la naissance à dance d'un
contre-pouvoir ouvrier solidarité
et c'est pour rendre hommage aux
victimes des émeutes du 17 décembre 70
que les syndicalistes ont fait ériger
une croix d'acier dédiée à ceux qui sont
tombés il y a 11 ans sous les balles de
la milice
dès l'aube ce matin radio Varsovie
annonçait que la police est l'armée
avait reçu l'ordre de tirer en cas
d'incident alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé en Pologne aujourd'hui c'est
presque on sait oui d'après ce que l'on
sait il n'y a pas eu officiellement ou
officieusement de racents de
rassemblement populaire dans toutes les
villes polonaises pour fêter ce onzième
anniversaire des émeutes de danse radio
Varsovie et on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure à la télévision polonaise aussi
à cependant reconnu et ce pour la
première fois que cette personne ont été
tuées et 39 autres blessés dans une mine
en Silésie toujours radio Varsovie capté
à Vienne de violents heures se sont
produits mercredi soir dernier
c'est-à-dire hier soir 160 policiers ont
été blessés à danse alors qu'il tentait
de disperser des manifestants 174 civils
ont été blessés également donc très
fortes résistance et détermination de
part et d'autre ce que nous savons aussi
c'est que les piscopa polonais a très
nettement durci sa position en
condamnant très fermement le coup d'État
militaire de dimanche dernier ce pouvoir
militaire qui continue d'arrêter des
membres solidarité c'est la radiographie
qu'il annonce cette radio Varsovie qui
est captée à Vienne il faut noter que
ces mesures d'arrestation touchent
désormais des membres modérés du
syndicat Solidarité comme Monsieur
geremax ce matin monsieur Stéphane
oloski membre du politique bureau qu'on
croyait en prison hier a donné une
conférence de presse devant les
journalistes est européens radio
Varsovie toujours annoncé que toutes les
entreprises industrielles de la capitale
marché tout à fait normalement et ce
depuis hier y compris la grande acierie
douta varsova c'est-à-dire aux alentours
de la capitale un journaliste ouest
allemand lui à son retour de Pologne
dans un article qui va publier demain
affirmer que des affrontements tu lieu
dans la ville de katowicche pardon en
Silésie c'est-à-dire dans le sud du pays
plusieurs centaines de blessés
affrontements également mésoconditionnel
cette fois dans les
usines d'Ursus près de la capitale
Varsovie voilà ce que nous savons pour
l'instant reste au cinquième jour du
coup d'État lors de règne pas tout à
fait les militaires ont forte affaire
avec deux forces de la nation à savoir
solidarité élément qui sont passés dans
la clandestinité depuis 4 ou 5 jours et
maintenant l'Église polonaise qui risque
de passer véritablement dans
l'opposition et Paul on ne sait toujours
rien du sort de lèvres
paraît-il est en résidence surveillée
aux alentours de Varsovie la capitale
depuis maintenant 2 jours et toutes
négociation ils seront le sait
officieusement ont été interrompus entre
lui et le gouvernement polonais mais le
gouvernement militaire la télévision
polonaise cherche maintenant à prouver
que solidarité se préparait en fait à
l'insurrection armée des caches d'armes
ont été découvertes regardez ce document
on a légèrement
de Varsovie des armes de fabrication
étrangères précisent le commentateur de
la télévision polonaise ont été trouvés
au domicile de deux ouvriers ces deux
hommes comme par hasard membres du
syndicat de solidarité et ses armes
ajoute le fonctionnaire ne sont pas des
armes qui servent à la chasse comme il
serait normal mais elles servent pour un
but qui veut être haute un but vraiment
militaire c'est le signe que solidarité
voulait ne pas en rester à une pure
action syndicale mais bien lutter pour
la conquête du pouvoir
et d'ajouter que le pouvoir militaire
fera tout pour empêcher de telles
exactions et déférera devant les
autorités
judiciaires les détenteurs de
telsarment des problèmes de
retransmission de ces images qu'il vous
le rappelle sont captées au Danemark et
puis une confirmation qui nous arrive à
l'instant l'ex valaisa est bien gardé à
vue c'est l'ambassadeur de Pologne à
Stockholm qui vient de le confirmer
deux jours en jours et on le voit encore
ce soir il y a plus guerre que les
sources officielles polonaises
amplifiées par les organes soviétiques
qui permettent de comprendre ce qui se
passe en Pologne toute la presse
occidentale est à l'affût des moindres
brides d'information ce qui permet à
l'agent stars de dire que je cite les
propagandistes bourgeois sont irritées
par la normalisation en Pologne on voit
en quoi consiste cette normalisation
plaque tournante des informations non
orthodoxes la Suède Gérard seva Guillet
que des informations fragmentaires et
parfois incontrôlables sur la situation
en Pologne savoir ce qu'il s'y passe
réellement relève d'une véritable chasse
à la formation qui mène les journalistes
dans tous les ports de Scandinavie de la
Finlande en passant par le Danemark et
la Suède en effet les quelques
informations que nous pouvons obtenir
proviennent de ces rares bateaux cargo
ou ferry boat qui traversent encore la
mer Baltique et c'est ainsi qu'a marin
un passager ou simplement un chauffeur
de poids lourds a remarqué quelque chose
que nous vous rapportons c'est ainsi que
ce soir à Stockholm nous avons appris
qu'il y aurait une radio au clandestine
qui émettrait à partir de dance mais il
est très difficile de la capter en
raison de la faible puissance de
l'émetteur et de la nécessité de changer
fréquemment d'emplacement pour ne pas
être repéré par la milice autre
information des groupes de jeunes
auraient attaqué ce soir des universités
et également des usines à Varsovie avec
des pierres et des barres de fer ces
usines sont évidemment entourées par la
milice et l'armée
plus de choses donc mais qui révèle tout
de même que la situation est loin de ce
normaliser ce qui est étonnant que nous
ressentons ici alors que nous sommes à
la porte de la Pologne et que nous
tentons d'y pénétrer c'est que l'on se
heurte à un véritable mur de béton avec
peu de fissures et en cela les autorités
de Varsovie ont réussi leur coup de
force car ainsi elles ont coupé ce pays
du reste du monde en cachant ce qui s'y
passe réellement oui sinon que ce soir
comme nous vous l'avons dit en début de
ce journal radio Varsovie et la
télévision polonaise ont évidemment
rendu compte ont été obligés de rendre
compte des violences incidents qui se
sont produits depuis hier soir autre
source d'information pour les
journalistes
occidentaux viennent en Autriche au plus
précisément la gare devienne ou le train
qui fait la liaison avec Varsovie le
Chopin Express a amené ce matin à son
maigre lot de voyageurs tous des
étrangers Pierre-Alain
ce train est le seul lien qui subsiste
avec la Pologne venant de Moscou il
s'arrête à Varsovie et Cracovie et
traverse la Tchécoslovaquie avant
d'arriver à Vienne tous les matins des
dizaines de journalistes venus des
quatre coins du monde États-Unis Japon
Grande-Bretagne Allemagne France
attendent les passagers du Chopin
Express qui sont littéralement assaillis
à leur descente car ils sont les seuls
polonais bénéficiant de la double
nationalité ou étrangers à pouvoir
apporter des témoignages sinon quelques
griffes d'informations les informations
imprécisent et impossible à vérifier et
qui sont le plus souvent le résultat des
rumeurs qui circulent tant bien que mal
en Pologne la plupart du temps la
réponse aux questions est je ne sais pas
je n'ai rien vu j'étais enfermé à
l'hôtel oui j'ai entendu dire que mes
enfants d'autres refusent tout
simplement de répondre ils sont
visiblement apeurés mais cette étudiante
italienne cependant
lundi était très tranquille mardi encore
hier il y a beaucoup des armées ça c'est
la chose qu'on a vu plus deux jours
avant mardi vous savez déjà que
l'Académie de Saya c'est fermé on a pris
des
travailleurs là-bas l'université
c'est ce que vous avez entendu parler de
fusillade
vous étiez traité comment est-ce qu'on
vous a obligé de rester à l'hôtel par
exemple
je ne pouvais pas quitter votre vie si
il faut demander l'autorisation pour
quitter la vie quelle est leur sentiment
en ce moment qu'est-ce qu'il pense
que l'armée elle est préparée de tout
peut-être 10.000 peut-être 30000
personnes on est sûr que l'armée est
elle est décidé on va il va gagner oui
elle va aller alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire alors tout le monde est déprimé ça
c'est le sentiment et tout le monde est
sûr que dans cette journée la situation
va être toujours pour plus
durer
depuis la fermeture des frontières
dimanche Beaucoup de Polonais sont
restés bloqués à l'étranger parmi eux
des membres de solidarité qui ont décidé
dans différents pays européens dans la
France de constituer des comités de
coordination ce soir dans différentes
villes d'Europe des avions charter sont
attendus qui doivent ramener de Varsovie
les étrangers qui s'y trouvaient encore
un avion est attendu à Orly dans une
demi-heure environ des Polonais vont en
profiter pour retourner chez eux
François cornet et parmi eux oui vous
parliez des gens de solidarité qui
avaient l'intention de former des
comités à l'étranger ce n'est pas le cas
de cette femme qui est à côté de moi
Stéphanie 52 ans je terrais son nom par
mesure de sécurité elle fait partie de
solidarité et pourtant elle rentre ce
soir à Varsovie pourquoi décidez-vous de
rentrer
parce que j'ai laissé mes enfants ma
famille c'est-à-dire les enfants
lesquels je m'occupe et après
quand les événements se passent et les
événements dangereux quand notre avenir
se pèse alors il faut que j'aille en
Pologne que je vis les événements avec
mes compatriotes et je suis polonaise
surtout que faisiez-vous dans solidarité
que quel était votre rôle exact j'étais
seulement membre je suis membre de la
solidarité
vous n'avez pas peur d'être arrêté en
arrivant à Varsovie
je suis tout petit tout petit trop trop
petite trop simple une question est-ce
que vous vous attendiez à cette vague
d'arrestation est-ce que vous pensiez à
solidarité que ça allait arriver
non
non je pensais que ça va réussir le
entre
encore avec l'aide de Prima de Pologne
et ça m'a surpris
d'une façon vraiment c'était un
étourdissement pour moi
vous êtes polonaise vous êtes de
solidarité que va-t-il se passer selon
vous maintenant est-ce que les gens les
membres de solidarité vont se révolter
oui ils vont se révolter évidemment
parce que c'est
injuste on ne peut pas
traiter des choses comme ça
c'est à dire selon les informations que
j'ai entendues
dire ce temps de temps d'arrestation ont
eu lieu
c'est quelque chose
non
terrifiant je vous remercie madame voilà
ils sont 250 polonais ici qui vont
reprendre deux charters qui doivent
arriver tout à l'heure à Orly 250
polonais qui vont donc quitter la France
pour regagner Varsovie à vous Christine
Ockrent oui et nous aurons donc d'autres
témoignages dans notre journal de 23
heures avec
les forces
vie parfois depuis le début de la crise
le Président réghane expose la position
des États-Unis cela se passe en ce
moment même à la baisse à la Maison
Blanche où se tient une conférence de
presse Edward alors vous êtes sur place
écoutez Christine je viens de voir un
président américain plus grave que je ne
l'ai jamais vu rappelant qu'à Noël
dernier c'était l'Afghanistan et que ce
Noël 6 et la Pologne ce qui me paraît
très important c'est que pour la
première fois Ronald Reagan a mis en
cause directement l'Union soviétique et
très nettement en disant qu'il faudrait
être naïf de croire que Moscou n'est pas
derrière tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en Pologne et il a ajouté
nous ne sommes pas naïves enfin si vous
voulez très solennel Ronald Reagan sans
préciser les moyens viennent de lancer
un appel pour que chacun pour que chaque
pays aide à ce que la situation
redevienne normale en Pologne
si on regarde a parlé de mesure
concrètes
vis-à-vis de la Pologne
là-dessus sauf ce que les États-Unis
pourraient faire et il a simplement
ajouté les rapports de violence ne sont
pas encore ici confirmés est-ce qu'il a
réaffirmé ou répéter sa mise en garde à
l'Union soviétique comme hier soir déjà
non il a été
beaucoup mis en regarde à l'Union
soviétique ni au gouvernement polonais
comme on l'a fait ici hier mais il a été
beaucoup plus loin en accusant
directement cette fois à Moscou et c'est
la première fois depuis trois jours
qu'on le fait ici à Washington merci
Édouard précisément tous les dirigeants
des pays membres du pacte de Varsovie
sont en train de se réunir en Moscou ou
doit avoir lieu demain un sommet des
pays membres du pacte de Varsovie une
réunion qui sera l'occasion de mettre au
point une attitude commune et
éventuellement une riposte en fonction
de l'évolution de la situation polonaise
déjà officieusement on laisse entendre à
Moscou qu'une intervention militaire ne
serait pas exclue de Moscou le
correspondant de l'AFP Patrick Menet
l'état de siège représente la dernière
tentative de solution polonaise en cas
d'échec l'URSS interviendra à Varsovie
cette phrase terrible est désormais
prononcée par les Soviétiques en privé
c'est un fait nouveau depuis 18 mois en
effet Moscou a affirmé sa volonté de
rester officiellement du moins en dehors
de la crise à présent un processus est
en marche personne ne sait à Moscou si
le général vient rouleski réussira à
stabiliser seul la situation hier les
Soviétiques étaient pessimistes
aujourd'hui ils sont plus sereins mais
ils savent que la moindre étincelle peut
mettre le feu aux poudres samedi les
dirigeants des pays communistes fêteront
au Kremlin les 75 ans de Léonie de
brejnef ils veulent que cet anniversaire
se déroule sans fausse note pas question
de précipiter les choses à Varsovie
avant dimanche m'a dit ce matin une
source officieuse mais après tout peut
arriver
en France nous n'avons pas encore ce
soir de réaction officielle à
l'aggravation de la situation en Pologne
ce matin le Premier ministre Pierre
Mauroy est revenu sur les moyens dont
dispose la France pour exprimer son
indignation en voie d'une mission du
Bureau international du Travail à
Varsovie demande aux partenaires
occidentaux de d'adopter une position
commune en fait Noël copain il faut bien
le dire les gouvernements même quand il
le souhaite quelqu'un de la France les
gouvernements ne peuvent pas faire
grand-chose au semble-t-il et bien oui
c'est impuissance et d'autant plus
fortement ressenti que le passé dans ce
domaine pèse nous il y a eu
l'impuissance au moment de la Hongrie en
1956 l'impuissance pour la
Tchécoslovaquie en 1968 la puissance
pour l'Afghanistan il y a deux ans et
puis dans un autre sens qu'a-t-on fait
pour le Chili c'est pourquoi je crois
Pierre Mauroy a fait cette réflexion
hier devant l'Assemblée nationale sur le
tragique décalage qu'il pourrait y avoir
entre les mots et la réalité tout le
monde se souvient de Budapest et des
illusions dont les mots des Occidentaux
ont bercé finalement en bernée et Léon
droit il est vrai qu'il y a peu de
possibilités et nous vivons dans le
prolongement en particulier de ces
fameux accords de galta qui ont partagé
le monde en deux et si ce partage
renforcé par l'équilibre nucléaire a
permis la paix dans le monde il y a des
pays qui peuvent perdre leur liberté qui
peuvent se payer cette équilibre de leur
liberté il est bien difficile
d'entreprendre des actions diplomatiques
surtout lorsque l'on en reste à ce
principe commode de la non-agérence et à
cette fiction d'une affaire polonaise
qui serait purement une affaire
intérieure et de toute façon même les
solutions qui ont été proposées ces
jours-ci même la proposition de Jacques
Chirac de remettre en cause des rapports
delsinki paraissent de peu de poids face
à la gravité de la situation en Pologne
il y a bien sûr les actions possibles
dans le domaine économique mais on a vu
ce que pouvait donner le blocus
américain au moment de l'affaire de
l'Afghanistan alors il reste cet appel
solennel à la conscience universelle
dont parlait tout à l'heure ce matin
Michel Jobert c'est peut-être une grande
et belle chose mais la bonne conscience
même à l'échelon de l'univers peut très
bien de rester qu'une
ce matin je lisais que notre confrère
libération lancette auprès de sélecteurs
une sorte de bourse aux idées et bien je
crains que les gouvernements n'en soient
là c'est en tout cas
cas une bonne terre en portant dit tout
à l'heure André Bergeron qu'il va se
forcer de faire partager à nos
partenaires de la communauté une sa
conception sur la Pologne il est vrai
que même s'il y a peu de choses à faire
il vaut mieux le faire ensemble et il
est vrai aussi qu'on ait un peu la
passion ces temps-ci que chacun
s'abritait derrière la prudence de
l'autre le gouvernement français je
crois de bonnes raisons d'essayer de
rompre ce climat d'abord parce que les
socialistes se sont toujours présentés
comme étant les champions et des droits
de l'homme et puis
Vanessa après dupechek même s'il est
conditions sont très différentes des
conditions françaises c'est quand même
cette alliance du socialisme et de la
liberté qui a toujours été le grand rêve
des socialistes français enfin il y a
tous ceux qui au mois de mai et juin
dernier ont pensé que le changement
n'était pas seulement un changement dans
les gestions politiques le risque serait
grand si les mouvements du cœur allaient
être brimés allaient être étouffée par
la raison des états le parti est commun
en tout cas nuance très légèrement sa
position le bureau politique du parti
souligne aujourd'hui que les communistes
je cite comprennent et partagent
l'émotion de tous ceux qui sont
sincèrement attachés aux socialistes et
aux libertés mais ils mettent en garde
contre les initiatives de ceux qui
n'hésitent pas à choisir le pire pour la
Pologne pour servir des objectifs de
politique intérieurs françaises 9
membres de la commission exécutive de la
CGT dont deux communistes Christian
Gilles et Jean-Louis moineau viennent de
publier une déclaration appelant les
travailleurs à se réunir dans les
entreprises et à discuter des modalités
de soutien aux travailleurs pour le nez
et notamment d'un arrêt de travail
officiellement la CGT reste toujours à
l'écart des autres syndicats les quatre
principaux syndicats qui démangent
avaient réagi avec vigueur à la
situation polonaise la CFDT FO la CFTC
et la scène ce sont réunis cet
après-midi pour décider de la poursuite
de leur action Laurence Graffin si la
CGC confirme demain à l'accord le
principe donné par son président elle
sera le cinquième syndicat avec la CFTC
FO la chaîne et la CFDT a signé l'appel
à un arrêt de travail pour lundi
prochain c'est arrêt prévu de 11h à midi
devrait se terminer par quelques
instants de silence dans les entreprises
dans les rues après mon maire hier André
Bergeron est allé auprès du gouvernement
plaider la cause de solidarité il a
rencontré le Président
je lui ai demandé d'intervenir auprès
des autorités polonaises en vue de la
libération des militants au prix
emprisonnés ces interventions seront
faites vous savez j'ai trouvé le
président de la République aussi
soucieux que moi aussi soucieux que nous
face à cette situation polonaise aussi
je dirais traumatisé parce qu'il se
passe là-bas seulement il est chef de
l'État il doit gouvernemer gouverner
dans un contexte international qui est
hélas celui que vous savez
pour vous la signification de l'arrêt de
travail prévue lundi c'est un moyen de
sensibiliser
l'opinion ouv rière sur ce qui se passe
en Pologne et de démontrer aux salariés
polonais qui finiront bien par savoir
quelles sont nos réactions leur faire
sentir qu'ils ne sont pas seuls
le Parti socialiste lance une pétition
nationale et avec le MRG le PSU la CFDT
et la scène organise un meeting de
soutien samedi à la Porte de Versailles
autre manifestation apolitique cette
fois organisée spontanément par des
lycéens un rassemblement d'enfants
silencieux aura lieu dimanche au Champ
de mars à 14h
à l'Assemblée nationale plus précisément
à la commission des affaires étrangères
le président du groupe socialiste Pierre
Joxe accusé le groupe UDF d'être un
réservoir de versaillais et d'utiliser
les événements polonais à des fins de
politique intérieure du coup monsieur
bar est deux de ses collègues ont quitté
la salle
tout doit être fait pour que la solution
du problème polonais soit recherchée par
la négociation et le dialogue le propos
est de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing l'ancien
président de la République était
aujourd'hui l'invité à déjeuner du
groupe
UDF de l'assemblée il a aussi parlé
politique française bien sûr il faut
jeter la rancune à la rivière a-t-il dit
l'intérêt de la France passe avant tout
face avant tout au ressentiment pour
l'ancien président le rôle de
l'opposition est de corriger les excès
du présent et de préparer l'avenir
revenons à l'Assemblée nationale les
députés ont adopté en seconde lecture le
projet de loi de finance pour 82 en
modifiant les taux de déduction fiscale
pour l'investissement sur proposition du
ministre du Budget Laurent Fabius les
industriels pourront déduire 15 % en 82
au lieu de 10 le chiffre du commerce
extérieur pour le mois de novembre
révèle un déficit de 6,4 milliards de
francs soit à peu près le même montant
que le mois précédent Renault interdit
d'exportation dans le monde arabe ou
plutôt dans les pays et ils sont rares
qui respectent la liste noire du bureau
de boycottage d'Israël Renaud et
coupable de commerce avec Israël Israël
a parfaitement réussi semble-t-il son
opération en annexant le Golan la Syrie
a déclaré aujourd'hui qu'elle se
considérait toujours liées par l'accord
de cessez-le-feu donc pas de riposte
militaire même si la série demande la
réunion d'une conférence inter-arabe
l'Assemblée des Nations Unies a bien sûr
condamné Israël
l'affaire du jour maintenant et bien
c'est encore une fois le procès de
l'affaire de Breuil qui touche à sa fin
hier plaidoirie de la partie civile
aujourd'hui réquisitoire de l'avocat
général Paul Lefebvre
que Le Fevre du palais de justice
c'est un fait criminel messieurs les
juré que vous avez à juger par autre
chose et l'avocat général a ajouté le
doute vient du fait que certains hommes
n'ont pas su faire face à leur
responsabilité ainsi je crois que
monsieur jean-lucré a rendu compte à ces
supérieurs des menaces potenti sur la
vie de Jean de brogue mais qu'il se tait
maintenant pour couvrir l'erreur de ses
services ainsi je crois que Monsieur
bonatowski aurait dû avouer tout de
suite à l'opiant public que ces services
avaient fait une faute aujourd'hui
termine l'avocat général aujourd'hui le
doute nous fait payer ses erreurs un
doute que les avocats des quatre accusés
vont à partir de demain tenter diriger
en système de défense
oui et nous apprenons à l'instant les
peines requises par l'avocat général 20
ans contre Pierre de Varga considéré
comme le commanditaire de l'assassinat
de Jean de Breuil 20 ans aussi contre
Guy Simonet le policier organisateur 15
ans contre le tueur Gérard fraîche 6 à 7
ans contre Serge Teissedre
l'intermédiaire entre l'assassin et
Simonet
un prix pour l'un d'entre nous Louis
Doucet journaliste Antenne 2 un prix
d'histoire décerné aujourd'hui par
l'Académie française pour son livre
quand les Français cherchaient fortune
aux Caraïbes le Grand Prix de l'Académie
française a été décerné à Jacques
Laurent pour l'ensemble de son œuvre et
le grand prix du roman à Jean Raspail
les résultats du quartier de Vincennes
maintenant le 5 le 10 le 3 et le 14 le
rapport pour 5 francs dans l'ordre
87624 francs dans un ordre différent
2159 francs 50
le mauvais temps continue de faire des
ravages le Sud-Ouest est toujours inondé
et en montagne la neige isole certaines
stations
la situation due au mauvais temps et aux
pluies et de plus en plus préoccupante
dans le Sud-Ouest ou le plan Orsec a été
déclenché toute la région est sous les
eaux on le compte plus les villages et
les fermes complètement isolées le
téléphone et l'électricité coupé les
cultures inondées et beaucoup de bétails
noyés
toutes les communications sont
interrompues et la vie économique
paralysée
les secours acheminés sur place ont
permis de sauver de nombreuses personnes
il est tombé en 5 jours sur le sud-ouest
de la France une fois et demie la
quantité d'eau qu'il tombe normalement
en un mois la Garonne est après de 65 cm
à 65 cm près au niveau de sa plus grande
crue enregistrée c'était en mars 1930
un matériel important a été mis en œuvre
hélicoptère bateau la gendarmerie la
protection civile et l'armée participent
au secours
parenthèse chargée de mission par le
gouvernement à survoler aujourd'hui
toute la région et remettra un rapport
en prévisions pour demain maintenant à
l'agile au Pétré bien je vous confirme
ce que je vous disais hier cela ne va
pas s'arranger du tout sur le Sud-Ouest
cette nuit il va pleuvoir sur le
Sud-Ouest mais il n'y a pas que le
Sud-Ouest Lille et le rein sont en côte
d'alerte en Alsace la Loire la Nièvre et
l'Allier commencent à être en crue cette
nuit ça ne va pas s'arranger en effet
pourquoi et bien parce que cette
dépression qui s'est formée hier demain
se situera sur la France après être
passé sur le Sud-Ouest tourbillon de
nuages pluie et puis pour si vous voulez
un petit peu plus loin samedi le froid
va descendre ici et la dépression qui
arrivera maintenant dimanche va heurter
ce froid et va donner de la neige bref
ça ne s'arrange pas ni pour demain ni
pour après-demain ni pour dimanche
région Paris Région maintenant après que
vous aurez dit que le baromètre est en
baisse et que le thermomètre pour demain
aussi est également en baisse région par
région donc le mauvais temps demain aux
alentours de midi se situera du nord-est
du pays au centre et à la Corse où il
pleuvra beaucoup beaucoup de neige
également au nord-est et sur les Alpes
ailleurs toujours froid au nord du pays
mais du Nord à la Bretagne
golfe du Lion tant variable instable
avec quelques éclaircisse certes mais
beaucoup de passages nuageux accompagnés
de pluie ou de neige sur les Pyrénées
d'orages sur le Sud-Ouest et de Rafale
devant assez forte de nord-ouest sur les
côtes de la Manche et de l'Atlantique
les températures prévues pour demain
toujours fraîche au nord de la Seine
baisse générale mais toujours très doux
en revanche encore 15 et 16 degrés à
Ajaccio et Bastia puisque nous sommes
jeudi nous allons faire pour la première
fois les bulletins de neige pour ceux
qui vont partir pour les sports d'hiver
sachez que pour d'abord les Vosges le
Jura les Alpes du Nord le Dauphiné les
Alpes du Sud pas de problème il y a
beaucoup de neige il s'agit de la
moyenne des hauteurs de neige au plus
hautes altitudes neige en centimètres
pour les Pyrénées et le Massif Central
là il y en a pas beaucoup il va tomber
sur les Pyrénées quand même cette nuit 5
et 10 cm les Pyrénées mais 110 cm au Pic
du Midi pour terminer notre éphéméride
demain c'est le vendredi 18 décembre le
soleil se lèvera à 8h41 se couchera
16h53 c'est le dernier quartier de lune
on la verra pas et demain c'est la Saint
Gatien aussi
dernier journal à 23h30 avec Jacques
Merlino je vous rappelle l'information
essentielle de ce journal le sang a
coulé en Pologne cette mort est plus de
300 blessés selon Radio Varsovie à
Washington le président Regan mais
directement en cause l'Union soviétique
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal je vous
retrouverai demain à 20h bonne soirée
sur Antenne 2